all right let's let's get back to some
of these indicators you use different
number of indicators to trace the rise
and fall of global economic power uh but
you pay particular attention to how much
debt a country has why is that
well it's a reflection of their
financial condition as you know in the
book there are 18 measures education
and civility with each other
and productivity are the most important
influences if you have a well-educated
population and education also means
civility with each other
and you're productive you have
productivity that's the greatest source
of stability and strength
the indebtedness
is a reflection of the fact that you're
spending more than you are earning
and that means that someone's financial
debt is another man's financial assets
and so there are right now over 30
trillion dollars in u.s dollar
denominated debt that someone is holding
as an asset that is being inflated away
that produces a dynamic that produces an
inflationary spiral because people want
to sell those bonds well they can't
there's too many of those and they can't
so in almost all cases of the decline
before there's the war the internal war
or the external war you always see this
dynamic rising dynamic of death and the
printing of money